[Music]
hello everyone i'm grand master dance
board
and this is insane in the end game and
today i'm going to
talk about the masters of the end game
the people who knew how to
do the best of the best they knew how to
get
the smallest advantage and then bring it
on home from there
so what you saw in caleb demby's
sessions how to survive difficult end
games this time you're going to learn
how to win them all right so let's jump
on in
with this game between ulf anderson and
shonia
neto it is going to be kind of the theme
of the day it is a
catalan variation
we're going to fast forward in the
middle game part
and we are going to stop
over here just for a moment so this is a
typical typical catalan position
without having a safe king
about black having solid development as
well and is also
just a single move away from castling
now it's not that anderson
is winning or even better for that
matter
he is going to slowly slowly
squeeze that little advantage that looks
so minuscule it's 92 knight takes c5
rook c1 castles so
before we kind of make
any sort of progress here we've got to
take a look
at the strongest pieces for black
now one of the strongest pieces that
black has is
this bishop on b7 which
is neutralizing white's bishop on g2
sort of ghostbusters style making sure
it is trapped
over there so here in this case
we will have to come up with a plan to
neutralize that pressure
so i would advise you to take a little
bit of a look here and a little bit of a
thing
because of anderson's next move is
crucial
for his strategy so note
that this bishop is pretty strong there
but apart from that bishop being very
strong
we have ways to go against it
so at first blink it looks that this
pressure on our queen
is annoying but anderson
does not really believe so actually
he does not even care goes 91
and says yes you may have a jump
in the future but i will just move my
queen away
meanwhile knight e1 activates this
bishop
and in case of any knight jumps the
bishop will be under some pressure
rook fd8 queen b1 just moving away
from these dangerous
threats and jumps rook c7
and just by looking at the position you
can tell
that anderson isn't even nursing an
advantage right now
black has two beautiful nights in the
center
but this is the moment you have to think
outside the box
and realize how anderson can improve on
his pieces
this is the second step we got to find
out
what would be a perfect way of trying to
untangle
as white in this position
keep into consideration that
as soon as we can get the rock queen
out white will have some extra space so
even though
visually this does look very appalling
for white we can just like
spring out of there once we get rid of
black's best pieces
so the first logical idea would be
to go and play knight d3
but knight d3 would run into ideas such
as
takes queen takes and knight f4
hitting both the bishop and the queen on
d3
which looks too dangerous and anderson
does decide to avoid that
and instead chooses the move knight to
e4
the point is this knight itself was sort
of loose
undefended and a potential
weakness in the position so he decides
to go there
trade it enough for a knight that was
already dominating
rook c8 knight takes c5
rook takes c5 rook takes c5
rook takes c5 so black is by no means
worse
just yet but white did improve on the
situation
by trading now this is somewhat unique
if you think about it because most of
the cases
trades do not lead to advantages
but in this case it actually to
wolf anderson's benefit as the
legend that is old vanderson knows that
in the long run
it's black who has to fear for the end
game
so we see that the rook and queen is
all stuck on e1 and b1
so he quickly brings the queen to d1
now as there have been rook trades
on the c file you have no threats on the
queen anymore
and the queen is comfortable back in its
initial squares rook c4
so now here comes the big question for
us which square will be useful
or in fact pivotal for us to grab
the advantage as of anderson
so far black is doing fine black
controls
the d5 square and also
has all the entry squares under control
what would be a logical way and away
that has been used by anderson so far
trading of course old fenderson
goes rook c1 this rook anyways wasn't
doing anything
spectacular it is much better off
traded especially versus a rook which
was kind of threatening to invade
and queen c7 was on the cards as well
so rook takes c1 queen takes c1
now this didn't answer our big question
which
square will be critical there is
one critical square in this position
which is essential for a right advantage
which square could that be
so notice that white just traded off any
pieces
that were in the way and kept the rest
that can be useful
in the end game
and the answer is it's the c5 square
so if the knight can hop on to c5
not only we would get a wonderful piece
on
that square but also we would target the
bishop and the pawn on a6
so even though this position seems very
tepid from a first look black
has to deal with a weak queen side
why white has no weaknesses whatsoever
black will also have to deal with that
king weakness on g8
so knight b6 queen takes b7
bishop takes b7 that is queen takes b7
so chess is not just about
achieving your own goals but about
restricting
your opponent's play and ulf's next move
actually is more restrictive in nature
than actually going for his own plans
and that actually is a sign of a true
champion true champions
usually make sure the opponents doesn't
really have a good plan anymore and then
they continue on with their own ideas
so here wolf played queen c5
very very strong move if black would
face knight d3 potentially
black could reorganize with knight d5
and just consolidate but with queen c5
it's actually making sure there are no
queen d5 moves because you always have
to look out
for queen takes b6 ideas
actually knight d5 and we do transpose
knight d3
and you can feel the difference white's
knight
is heading and is closer to the a pawn
while the screen is sort of relegated to
defend
the b and a pawns which
is of a detriment also
in the long run this king might be a
little bit closer than its counterpart
which still has to deal with some back
rank issues and that's actually
a little bit of a benefit of the catalan
you already have a loft
so any check you'd get there is a king
ji to move
and the king could run away queen c7
and shunyanetto who's a grandmaster
himself
thinks that a queen trade should
definitely
lead to a draw but is that really the
case
well the answer is no it's not a draw
and in fact oof is just happy to play e4
here
now black is forced to trade knight
can't move otherwise you lose the queen
so queen takes knight takes if knight b4
i can just go a3 then pick up the a pawn
and then you see how glorious this
knight is
on that c5 square it not only attacks
the a pawn it also takes away
this innovating square from the black
knight
and after knight c6 you just win a pawn
on a6 and white is just completely
winning
with an extra pawn so here neto
had to go knight c7 but this is
what we call domination the knight on c5
is completely dominating
the c7 one now
domination does not necessarily equal a
winning position
so ulf anderson will still have to do
and put in
some work to win it he has
this control over the night there are
some targets on the queen side but in
order to win
and any end game and especially this one
you need a second weakness so this was
the first one on the queen side but need
another one so the question is where can
we find
that other weakness which side
or where
now apart from finding weaknesses
you also have to keep in mind your
opponent's plans as i said
part of your goal in chess is to
restrict your opponent's play
and then follow up with your own
so anderson's next move isn't just about
uh facilitating his own plans so f4 is
not just about
bringing the king in but it's also about
stopping this eventual plan
of king f8 king e7 king d6 with a
potential e5 move
just keeping that king locked on in so
let's say here
here here vine may just go e5
making sure the king is boxed in and
then white can continue on
with his plants he could try to go this
way
although eventually there might be an a5
move
or go the g for king e4
f5 way trying to pressure the e pawn and
creating
an extra passer on the king's side
and that combined with these weaknesses
could prove decisive
now shunya understood this idea of ant
f6
himself notes that he can just wait idly
because in that case he's just gonna get
smothered
king f7 king f2 king f7
b4 again in
the same idea first off trying to
restrict
and this time making sure the knight
cannot hop around anymore
nor does black have the move a5 now
a5 if you play it now it's still
not necessarily a great move for black
because in that case y can go knight b7
a4 and then this king can do a little
bit of a home run
and once it reaches the c5 or b6 square
it is technically winning for white
because if the b
pawn falls so does the game get lost
but after king f2 king f7 b4 fixes the
spawn on a6
eternally the same thing with the f i
mean
the c7 knight that
knight will always have to guard that a6
square
so that sort of means we're technically
in a pawn end game
from black's perspective e5
king f3 and this is not
your usual opposition but it is by the
way
considered an opposition this is what we
call
a distant opposition between the two
kings
g6 and this is probably the most
important moment here anderson
will have to decide which direction he
wants to go to
is he trying to come up with a plan on
the queen side is he continuing on on
the king side
and if he does is he trying to
slow outplay his opponent or try to a
more direct approach
so let's try to think about that for a
minute
so one hint in these type of positions
is checking out your opponent's moves
what can shunyanetto do in this position
well the knight can't move as we said
before
it's stalemated on c7 it is lorded by
our knight on c5
so the only things that shunya could do
is either rotate the king back and forth
or start moving
these hg and f-bonds those are the moves
that are possible for black
now once we get into an end game
position
it is all about the little nuances
and whether we can out-tempo
our opponents and anderson decides
i am willing to go for the end game
i have many reservoir moves
so he goes king g4 and sets up this
threat of king g5
if you don't react go king e7
white is just going to go king g5 and
once i invade
that square you will be overloaded let's
say
you go try to play play this passively
there is knight d7
you're losing the e5 pawn and you lose
the game as well
your king and knight is just way too
passive to get enough counter play
but if you go king f6 you run into
knight d7 check
if the king goes to e6 knight f8 check
and you lose the pawn
so even though it looks like a simple
position
defending this with black is not at all
trivial
you can't just block me with king f6
you can't just ignore me with king e7
because i run run on in same with king
g7
i go knight d7 and i immediately win the
e pawn
as the king can't cross on over there
so the only move that sunya considered
the best is h6
sort of creating a wall of pawns
saying that there will be no passage
but this turn ought to be flawed
right can break through
so oftentimes it's not necessarily
about euro moves
but about potential plans and attacks
your opponents can do
here it's important to understand that
sunya is
almost in a suits wrong situation where
he
can't really maneuver too much
so next move was h4 he's saying
that if i get h5 in there if i could
trade that
this will lead to an advantage for me
because then i'll get access to the f5
square
which conversely will give me the e pawn
and the game
so if you go king g7 i go h5
and i'm just coming too close g5
that just means success for white
i'm just walking on in picking up the
pawn in the game over
if you take i can take here
i can start rolling with my pawn
get the opposition whichever way you go
i can come on
in there or just simply pick up the pawn
that way
so sriniv was forced to play h5
king g5 a little risky it's almost
checkmate but thankfully we've got our
hero of the game
the knight on c5 to stop that checkmate
take it and just take all those pawns on
g6 and h5
king g7 g4 trade them all
takes king takes king f6
now even in this case
extra little moves are crucial
so i said earlier it feels like
a king and pawn engi but in fact
it's still that knights so sometimes
black can't think about giving up a pawn
just for active play
so ulf doesn't even go h5 first
he goes a3 because black
believe it or not doesn't have anything
else
apart from a king move the knight is
still stuck there
and you still have to guard this idea of
knight d7
attacking the e pawn so you can just go
king g7 same idea of knight d7 i'm
taking the e pawn
king f7 king g5
king g7 and once the king is gone
and away white goes knight d7
and he's winning the e pawn check
king g4 knight d4 and still props
for shunyanetto of anderson's opponent
tries to activate the knight because he
knows
that in an end game your best chance is
peace activity
i take c5 knight c2
and seemingly this does not look great
for off however
anderson knows the best defense
is to counter attack
so he goes knight d7
knight takes a3 knight c5 he gives away
the a pawn but says i'm going to win
your a pawn as well
and i've got that extra pawn to work
with
and with the pawns being on both sides
and both ends of the board
it's much more difficult for sunya to
actually organize successful defense
knight takes a6
king f3 king e3
91
and again shunya is not giving up
so even though he's not going to succeed
in this game
his level of tenacity
does match the tenacity that you see
in the current top players
they're also very tenacious and this is
something
well worth taking from these legendary
players
so again got to wonder should we
just try to over defend the e and h
pawns
or look for something more active
so here of actually decides to go e5
you could try to go king f4 and that's a
different kind of strategy
saying i'm going to over defend all of
these pieces
however then you can't really
base your ideas on peace activity
when anderson decides to go e5 he's
saying
i am willing to part with this pawn
but for an exchange i am
going to have very very good piece play
myself
with certain threats of promoting myself
so black doesn't even want part of that
king f7
king e4 knight g2 knight c7
takes knight takes b5 and
with the pawn just being so
far away from that square the king being
too
close and these pawns fairly advanced
black is just lost knight f5
knight d4 and again a tendency why you
should know your basic pawn
end games a trade would lose immediately
because at the end of the day
you can't capture either of those pawns
because the other one would just promote
so knight d4 anderson is happy to
offer this idea from forshuni
knight e7 b5
king d5 here and king c5
and you always wonder so
is the king knight and pawn end game the
same
as a king and pawn end game no it's not
the same
the knight will be successful enough
to stop this g-pawn from promoting while
this knight is helpless against the
b-pawn running down the board
and that kind of shows that domination
can often win you a chess game
especially deep down in these
end games so the second game i want to
show you guys is the game between
semi reschevsky and hermann pillneck
it is exactly the same opening
leading to these type of end games
rook c8 a4 take stakes
knight c3 c5 and at first look
it again looks very tepid solid
and not at all aw inspiring
however compared to the previous game by
ulf
anderson vine has more targets than
before
so the first things first you always
have to identify
your future weaknesses you're going to
latch on to
so let's try to identify that first
then we can continue on rashevsky
of course decided to take on d5 bishop
takes d5
and now he wondered of course if you
take on e6
now that wouldn't be winning there is
bishop takes
f3 bishop takes and c takes and
black is by no means any worse black
will be building a center with e5
and will be having a great position
so that is the that is not the move that
rushevsky played here
so first step identify weaknesses
second step go after them
and actually this kind of shows that
even though fisher got most of the
limelight
towards the 70s for understandable
reasons
rushevsky was a master of this game
especially
a big master of end games he knew
when to put the pressure and how to put
the pressure correctly
and ruschwski's next move rook fc one
even though
does not strike maybe the average
people spectacular it is
very very useful of a move
it puts pressure on the two big
weaknesses
that pelnick has the a6 pawn and the c5
pawn
first off he is trying to put pressure
there
and once there is a little bit of a
trade there he can
divert his attention to the a6 one
now it takes d4 now if they would take
on f3
we take back c takes queen takes d4
and with pawns on both sides and both
ends of the board
this is a little bit better for white
because the
bishop will be much more comfortable
attacking that a pawn
in fact sometimes could go e3 bishop e2
so let's say knight to b8 there is a
potential idea of going e3 bishop e2
and go after the a pawn but pelnick
decided to take on d4
knight takes d4 takes
king takes and again this
is a little bit different from the
mihal tal type of chess here you're
accumulating the smallest of advantages
possible
and try to win nevertheless
so there are a couple of things that we
improved upon
since the position we looked at
there is still this a6 weakness also
look at this knight on d4
it just hopped into that center square
and we are about to target the c6 square
if the knight can hop over there
white will get a beautiful bind on pill
neck
so let's say if black goes here
for one rook c7 is very strong but even
if you don't
feel like going in there immediately
after knight c6
black will be in full control
as all of these pieces are going down
there in fact knight d7
would be winning on the spot
so accumulating small advantages
can actually win your game much quicker
than you think it would
knight b8 knight to beat is a sad move
and it shows
that rushevski's advantage is
substantial
misplaces this knight intentionally just
to stop knight c6 ideas which wouldn't
really work
due to queen b7 and that pin on the king
so if you go here queen b7
you're pinned and you're actually losing
and if you remember the first lesson
from the olf anderson nato game
you can use the same logic and technique
in this rushevsky game you know your
opponent's threats
restrict the idea if you can restrict it
you are halfway there
so we already kind of suspect that black
would love to get the queen to b7
and then maybe in a bright future play
e5
i'm a little bit hesitant with the e5
pawn move
because it would create a target on e5
as that pawn would not have this
support by the f7 pawn
kind of shows that queen b7 is
a plan therefore reshefsky decides to
play queen b3 himself
just denying that square from pilnek
now let's just take a look around what
ruschevsky
i mean semirachewski has accomplished
there is still a weakness on a6
that knight is very very bad on b8
we don't have an immediate control over
the c6 square
but our knight is just much better than
yours
i mean our knight is just much better
than
our opponents much much better
so there's a weakness a bad night and in
general
we're the one controlling the situation
they can't even check us
rook cd8
now rook cd8 is an interesting choice by
pilnik
usually when you're kind of lacking
space
you would be thinking of trading so
maybe it would have been
in hindsight better to trade on c1
but he goes rogue d8
and whenever you're
trying to make advantages like this
you've got to remember
that one little slip
can let the advantage go
for for example if you go knight f3 then
black can
slowly try to consolidate with going
rook d6 and maybe eventual
either knight d7 or knight c6
so reshefsky is staunch on leaving that
knight on d4
just making sure that c6 square is still
under his control
rook d7
just trying to double up
somewhat of a passive move but
it doesn't make our lives easier that's
why we still
need to come up with a plan
obviously we can't really play on the
king's side
pill nick is way too solid there
and ruschevsky's next move by the way is
reminiscent of a boxing style rook a5
the point being it's trying to push back
black fixing the target fixing the
weakness
and then piling upon it same in boxing
you make sure that you get your opponent
in a tough spot and you try to go on
from there
okay five and in fact this has a dual
purpose
not only does it press on the a pawn but
it sort of dissuades pelnick from ever
playing e5
because any time you do that what would
be
able to counter attack immediately
rook b7 queen a3 and
queen e3 sort of shows that we're not
in here to win it in a tactical fight we
are here
to win the long grind so let's say if
you take on a3
pawn takes like y does not have the
luxury to take it with the rook
this would be a drawn end game even if
we went the a6 spawn
it would just even out so we've got to
play
and take with the b pawn but our threats
will be
quite strong after knight c6
because even if they trade
they'll always be an a7 i mean an a6
pawn weakness
and rook c8 does not really work due to
this idea of knight d7
check and then you lose
the rook and the knight is even
on b8 so queen a3 queen b4 a cheeky
response by pilnek
but not a terribly
dangerous one
so rushevski's next move is more about
consolidating than anything else
he goes rook c2 he's not really afraid
of trades he's okay with that but now by
the way
if takes we might actually consider to
take
with the rook because eventually we
could play b3 as our knight will be
right there to guard
the b pawn while this a pawn is going to
be
under constant pressure so rook c2
g6
and it is time for us to come up with a
new game plan
so far so good we consolidated we have a
very very strong knight on d4
we have pressure on the a pawn we've got
this pawn all
guarded but now we have to look for a
new plan
that is a mighty night there
so apart from the a pawn in the long
term
actually black has this knight as some
sort of a target
so rushevsky decides to actually leave
the a pawn alone
and look for another plan and that is of
invading
the eighth rank because then that b8
knight will become a nuisance knight d7
and hiroshevsky does the curious thing
of repeating now there's always a talk
why super grandmasters ever repeat
well it has to do with the fact of the
time controls that you're
often trying to mark time and get closer
to the magical
number of 40 because that was
traditionally
the time control time so if you got to
move 40
you will get additional time to use for
the later part of the game
so it makes sense for rashevsky to
repeat one
and then come up with a new plan so he
of course does
not want to repeat goes through k4
he doesn't mind the trade but pilnek
actually doesn't want
any thing to do with that in b6
and now he goes rook c4 no more threats
of trading
and eventually now ruxiate does become a
threat
now remember this knight is sword are
still stuck
if you ever move that knight you are
just inviting white to get the knight to
c6
which puts immense positional pressure
on pill next position this might be very
close to losing already
talking about that like a random move of
h5
white can't go rook b4 and believe it or
not
the queen is trapped you can't go to
those squares
if you go queen c7 there's 97 check and
you lose the queen
over there so here pill nick
started to get desperate for a good
reason
white is about to crash through so you
went for e5
knight f3 and it's very admirable how
rushevski plays this
whole game coolly calmly and collectedly
not really rushing the situation saying
pillnik is the one under pressure it's
pilonic who has to make tough decisions
i'm just going to wait for the right
moment and here
pink played the move that
would make a some certain ben
cringe played f6
and the reason f6 is not a good move and
i of course agree that
ben it leaves
the king awfully exposed
on g8 and they're no longer any guardian
pawns in front of the king
so yes black managed to gain some space
but if sammy rushevski manages to invade
the position
that invasion is going to get decisive
and it all has to do with this f6 move
rook c8 chevsky is not waiting no longer
if you would take take
its checkmate checkmate on f8
rook c8 queen b4
and there has been a lot of changes
since the middle game slash and game
position we looked at
white had a little bit of pressure on
the a-pawn but
no real attacks on the king but by now
black has over-extended created plenty
of targets
so rashevsky wants no business
with a queen trade so ghost queen d3
not really falling for e4 which
visually looks like a win
so screen d5 check and the knight will
just hop away
let's say rook have 7 knight d4
and this is that typical position that
looks even because the pawn count
is even but in reality it's just
completely lost
for pelnek because black's king
is just awfully exposed while arcing on
g2 as
straight up chillin
so queen d3 rook f7 e4
and e4 is again that typical rashevsky
style
slowly but surely moving forward
not trying to rush the win that is of
course
better so he's not
looking for a winning blow just yet
queen b7
so this is the moment you do have to
look around
pelnick is about to smoke out the rook
on c8 and we can't really go to c7
because that's garden by the queen and
rook
and it seemingly is no way to break
through that case
so this is probably the
most important technical part of the
game
where reshefsky is going to decide it in
his favor
so it is white to move and
take control of the situation
so if you don't have any entry squares
on the 8th or the 7th well
chess is about problem solving create
create an entry square for yourself
rook takes fa check rook takes f8
queen d6 and queen d6
is an all-star move doesn't want to just
take
any file like you could try
to go in there with queen c7
but no reshevsky wants more reshefsky
wants
domination wants to make sure that
knight
doesn't have any way out you go knight
d7
bam it already loses the queen and
knight is under attack and you're going
to lose one of them
you can't go to c6 and the next move
is rook c7 followed by queen e7
and with the tractor on c7 and the queen
all lined up
it is just game over so you really don't
have time to take on e4
even though that looks juicy because of
this idea of rook c7
and an eventual queen e7 which is just
checkmating so in desperation
pillnik went for queen d7 and obviously
in this case
we don't want to trade queens goes queen
b6
and you might be wondering okay okay you
taught me
you told me about these pawn weaknesses
but why does that
matter well black would love to trade
off this c
rook but that would lose on the spot due
to the fact that
there's rook takes and queen takes f6
now you're going to lose the e
pawn and you're going to get checkmated
as well
so because of these pawn weakenings
black is just lost on the spot and can't
do
the strategically sound idea of rook c8
queen f7 which is a sad
concession now roshewski goes rook c7
and in comes the rook and queen
between e8 of course if you go knight d7
then white can take on a6
so queen e8 three and b7
and now with the rook
planning to invade the king and setting
up mate
so black would just ignore that do
some sort of a desperado that would be
made in three
again talking about domination
so pelnek played rook f7
just making one last
desperado but of course after rook takes
f7
queen takes f7 v8
he's losing a piece and he resigned
so these were the games i wanted to show
how you can pile a little bit of
pressure
at a time wolf anderson style
roschevsky style go step by step
and eventually they'll break thank you
so much for watching
and see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you